hello everyone and welcome to what could
very well be the perfect game it's alpha
zero with the white pieces against alpha
zero with the black pieces but with one
very strong exception in this version of
chess castling is not allowed
now why is casting not allowed you might
say well do you know what email kramnik
of course you do a legend you know
former world champion well even though
he retired it seems that he didn't lose
all that much interest in chess because
here he discussed this idea with some
good people at the deepmind demis
hassabis in this and some other
gentleman I will put a link in the
description below where you can read
more about this but basically Kramnik
said that professional chess is becoming
very boring and he mentions that in the
Watchers Championship match between
Carson and Caruana all 12 classical
games ended in a draw which is not
surprising since they have to go into
pre-prepared lines you know down the
memory lane and basically bullets out 20
or so moves and then it's basically a
position where where the position is
equal and both of them are able to hold
this
now here also kramnik mentions that you
do have Fischer random chest or chess960
that Wesley saw is now the world
champion of it's interesting but a lot
of players don't like it and even a very
top elite players some of them don't
like it as they don't feel comfortable
playing it so here kramnik proposes a
variant of chess that's the basically
normal chess so you can still apply
normal openings you're just not allowed
to the castle and here what they did in
deep mind they let alpha zero learn
itself just from the beginning like they
did you know when alpha zero started the
learning just but with the exception
that castling is not allowed in this
version of chess so what what happened
is is that the games became much more
interesting well from a human standpoint
of course we enjoy you know crazy
sacrifices you know open lines
that a lot of stuff is happening on the
board we don't enjoy slow maneuvering
positions where it's you know maybe I
will push this pawn someday so that's
basically it and this is one of the
games that is available in the article
so like I said the first thing you will
see in the description below is a link
to this article on chess calm it says
it's by one Mitt Romney himself so who
am I to you know to question that so do
check it out but now let's check out the
game and it's always well it's always
impossible to analyze alpha zeros games
because you cannot use a conventional
engine to check if alphas moves are good
or not and this is even harder because
here even if you have like an abnormally
strong stockfish maybe stalkers will
tell you okay that's a that that's a
good line
but it will not be working here because
castling is not allowed because stuff
which might say ok played that that and
then castellón move 7 that line is
useless to us because you're not allowed
to castle or move 7 for example but as
soon as one player moves the King oh
well after both players move the King
then you can again use conventional
engines to analyze your games because
then the position will somewhat be
comprehendible so without further ado
let's check it out let's just call them
alpha white and alpha black or maybe
alpha 1 and alpha 2 we'll see how he
goes I still haven't decided so the 2
moves are predefined so e 4 we have C 6
the caro-kann d4 and d5 so it is as of
this moment that both alphas are on
their own
we have Knight to c3 like you would
usually do D captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 and the knight to f6 and
here already a very interesting move by
alpha if you put this to any any engine
you will most likely get Knight Capra's
on f6 Queen d3 Bishop to d3 in some very
rare cases maybe even Knight to g3 but
here alpha just retreats the c3 and it
is a move that you will not very very
often see but okay like Kramnik mentions
in the article if you check it out you
know it's probably the best way to
develop your pieces so who are we to
argue with alpha with ecigs by alpha
Bishop to e3 and now
Queen to c7 I just you know nicely
developing and now H for something alpha
usually does playing on both sides of
the board pushing h4 h5 a4 a5 developing
the rooks not in the conventional way
you know Castle brings rook to e1 but
now you can do rook h3 rook g3 you can
put it upon 2 H 5 go rook h4 then you
immediately have the rook on the
fourth-ranked so very interesting as as
usual and now Kramnik mentions that in
some of the games they were analyzing
alpha replied with h5 to h4 but here we
have Knight bd7
we have a 4 now again playing on both
sides of the board awesome stuff
we have h6 canonic mentions in the
article most likely an early you know
the a defensive idea against the g4 and
g5 so you already have upon guarding g5
knights the f3 continuing development
and now a6 probably preparing c5 as well
if you just push c5 then the B 5 square
becomes available for the night
we have rush up the c-4 by alpha white
and then out Bishop to d6 again
developing and here you would see
probably castles castles if this was a
regular game but it's not so kink the f1
the King will be very safe there you can
develop the Queen you can bring the
other look over to e1 you can develop
this rook via h3 so a lot of
possibilities we have b6 by black and
now comes Queen to e2 as we discussed
Bishop to b7 now put a preparing to push
c5 this Bishop will then open up and
rook to e1 and here comes well now we
would most likely see queenside castle
or king size castle if this was a normal
chess game but here we have seen that
east 7 and it is of this moment as of
move 13 that you are now able to analyze
the position with conventional engines
because now castling is no longer
allowed and you can analyze it so better
back the b2 seems odd putting your King
on e7 or when you have the Queen and the
rook controlling the e-file but the idea
is probably bringing either of the rocks
here and then marching your King over to
the Kings side or marching the King to
the Queen side so basically you have the
castle artificially we have rook hd8
continuing with the plan and now
without wasting any time alpha white
needs to seize the initiative so here G
for offering the pawn Knight to e5 is
isn't all the great because of c5 you
challenge the the defender of the knight
on d5 and now just captures captures
you're gonna bring the other broker here
hide the King to c8 and the black will
be perfectly fine
so here g4 saying that okay if you
capture I have group g1 just not another
very nice pawn but I will get a
semi-open file for my rook an ID f6 and
now you're gonna go Knight to e5 where
you will have problems as black either
you will capture this guy here and then
after recapturing you will force this
knight back which will remove the
defender of the g4 night or if you
capture with this Knight then after
captures you open up the G file for the
rook so here after g4 alpha is not about
to be triggered by the other alpha so c5
not opening up this beautiful diagonal
and now comes d5 closing it and hoping
to open up the e-file King f8 of course
and now D captures on e6 and here is
where things get completely crazy and
one of the reasons why this is
definitely the perfect game so here
alpha black plays b5 now of course you
cannot capture anything here since your
queen would be hanging but there is
another really crazy line Queen to c6
which just well I will show it III mean
I'm just gonna show it so you're
offering
well you're threatening to capture on f3
so here Queen the d3 offering a trade
night for Bishop on d6 but now comes
Knight to e5 attacking the Queen and the
triple attack on the night so Knight
captures on e5 now Queen not captures on
h1 but Queen to g2 with check King to e2
and now Bishop captures on e5 and here
rook H to g1 pushing the Queen back
Queen to h2 and now white continues the
attack with g5 so the knight is under
attack pawn captures Bishop captures and
g5 and only now F captures on e6 and
here you would get Queen to g6 and you
have this incredibly complicated
position where anything can happen they
have it well obviously analyzed by
by alpha and it appears to be an equal
position but imagine you were playing
okay alpha is playing against alpha so
those are two opponents of the same or
you know maybe maybe very very close in
strength but imagine you if you had this
position against someone your own
strengths or maybe someone slightly
weaker or slightly stronger would you
call this position equal so that that is
what I asked you know just you know
ponder on that but okay alpha doesn't
just like to go this way
so instead b5 attacking the bishop with
a captures and b5 it's basically b5 is
to open up the a file for for the black
rook at some point so it captures an b5
and now Knight the b6 a with the threat
of Knight captures Bishop and then after
Queen captures you pick up the knight on
f3 so again there are two ways to go
about this rook h3 is one way just add
another defender to the f3 Knight and
now if Knight captures on c4 Queen
captures on C for a capture son b5
Knight captures sorry Knight captures on
b5 Queen moves and you have this
position where again alpha decides that
it's not not the best way to go
so after this night to be six we have g5
so continuing with the attack and okay
Knight captures on c4 now what do you do
here you could either capture or well
capture on c4 or capture energy on f6 if
G captures an f6 this doesn't work
because of Bishop captures on f3 and now
of course if you capture the Bishop
Knight captures and e2 with check picks
up the Queen and if you don't after
Bishop captures an f3 if you play Queen
captures on c4 then Bishop captures on
each one and after Queen to g4
threatening Queen captures on g7 mate
black has F captures on e6 and now this
opens up the Queen's defense to the two
the g7 phone and black will be now
better now so after Knight captures on
c4 you don't have G captors and f6 you
have to play Queen captures on c4 we
have Bishop captures on f3 and then now
rook the g1 just putting up a setting up
a rook for the for the G file that will
soon open up we have H captures on g5 h
captures
g5 that's not a capture H captors and g5
attacking the knight and not Knight the
g8 and here's a very interesting moment
we're in the article if you've checked
at you you've seen it Kramnik says that
this is the only good move and it's hard
for human brains to understand why this
is the only good move for example if you
try Knight d7 to try and give up some
material back to stop White's attack
then white has Queen to h4 a very
exciting stuff and now after F captures
on e6 you have g6 Knights to f6 and now
Bishop to g5 so whites whites attack
keeps mounting up Knights the g8 and now
Queen to h3 putting more pressure to the
east exponent but also attacking the
bishop on f3 Bishop back to b7 and now
the star move of the of the variation b6
this b6 is available through the entire
game but in most of the lines in black
just hates it
so here the b6 point is under attack of
course if you captured then you remove
one of the defenders of the seventh rank
so here let's say Queen to d7 if Queen
captures and b6 then you can just pick
it up rook captures rook captures Queen
captures on e6 now threatening mate and
after Queen to c7 defending now you have
Knight to d5 and if Bishop captures then
you have Queen captures on d5 and it
will just be very hard to defend this
even though you're up a piece let's say
rook e8 you're gonna get rook to h1 and
now for example rook h8 is coming the g8
and Knight is in trouble you could also
play rook h3 to f3 with Czech White will
be completely winning here
so after this b6 this sneaky poisonous
move Queen to d7 and now you get rook to
g4 and here you will well it's a very
interesting since black is still up a
piece but there are a lot of use useless
pieces for black this rook isn't doing
anything this rock isn't doing anything
the night can't really move you can't
really move the bishop the bishop must
be guarding the f4 square you don't want
to rope the forecheck you can push a 5v5
just runs into rook F for check picks up
the Queen so it would be well a much
better position for white and for alpha
that of course means a completely
winning game so
here after H captures ng5 night the g8
the only good move and now rooked III
attacking the bishop and here alpha has
the opportunity to trade down into into
an equal endgame with a cactus and b5
we're just gonna show it since it's very
interesting
a cactus Knight captures attacks the
Queen and the bishop now look the a1
check one of the reasons why da file was
opened up bishop the a1 blocking and now
Queen to a5 with a double attack on the
bishop here Knight captures and b6 but
now rook captures on e6 with B for now
this is all this is also very
complicated that it would take would
probably an entire video to analyze only
one of these moves so since this is a
sideline we're just going to mention it
Queen captures on b4 here we have a
trade to see captures and now rook
captures on e6 FCAT force on e6 r OG
three pushes the bishop back but should
be 5 and now finally King e2 unpinning
and the rook to be one we have well this
end game where the material balance is
completely equal and well alpha alphas
agree that this is a draw so s kramnik
mentions in the article both alphas are
in a fighting mood so Bishop the h5 not
interested in trading down into a draw
an endgame look the h1 attacking the
bishop and now Bishop to g6 if g 6g 6
losses to the rook captures on h5 it's
maybe hard to imagine that between 1200
captors and h5 would even be a you know
in the position but here it is G
captures and now b6 again trying to get
the Queen away from the defense of the
seventh rank and after Queen d7 G six
now and here white finally breaks
through so really incredible stuff so I
have to look to h1 we have Bishop to g6
by alpha black and now rook the f3 now
lining up the rook nicely with the King
here rook to e7
the only good move adding a defender to
the f7 pawn and now Knight to d5 again
there is the possibility of rook the h8
it seems like something tall would play
and then after eight characters on b5
Knight captures on b5 attacking the
Queen Queen to see
attacking the rook he captures on f7
threatening to capture with well
multiple discoveries rook captures on f7
and now rooked III you would get rook to
a one with Czech Bishop blocks and now
rook to d1 and hereafter Queen to e two
attacking the rook and also threatening
rook to e8 well if the Queen moves of
course rook the f5 is blacks star move
now the bishop also covers this square
and here basically if Queen captures
rook Queen captures a knight here with
Czech and it's well it's really just
really crazy stuff so although rook to H
it is possible Knight to d5 is what
alpha Y prefers now attacking the Queen
and the rook Queen to b7 now if Knight
moves then Queen captures rook on f3
with ECAP reason f7 rook captures on f7
and now again I know you guys are
already you know freaking out with all
the older all the Alpha moves but Bishop
f4 yes that's that's all we have to
check that out as well now the idea is
that of course if the piece is captured
then you get Queen captures on c5 with
check King has to now go for a walk
King g8 and now looked H it as the
knight is no longer defended so rook the
FA defending the knight and now c4 just
adding adding a defender to the night
after it captures and b5 now you have
rook captures and g8 rook captures and
g8 now you've removed the defender of
the bishop here rook captures on f4
Bishop to d3 check King t1 and now rope
to a7 adding another defender to the
seventh track rank and now see captors
on b5 and you get this position where
black is up a whole rook but this rook
or this rook isn't really doing all that
much you can give one share for example
rook rook e1 but then King D 2 comes
with tempo and well the black king is in
the middle of the board it's white white
who is to be preferred here
so after Bishop to f4 we have Bishop to
e7 and now all of a sudden b6 and now
alpha white gets this powerful past b6
pawn and now who amongst us remember
how this pawn even got to be sex I mean
it's it's really amazing stuff the
thread is Knights the c7 which comes
with an attack on the rook and then the
cuttin the knight wants to come to east
six deliver this deadly check so you
have to prevent this rook the d8 the
only good move and still Knight the c7
if Knight captures any 7 it's also
possible but we have Luke captures on e7
now the rook is under attack rook h2 h3
defending it
Bishop to h5 now offering a bishop for a
rope here Bishop to d6 now I discovered
check you give up one rook Bishop
captures rook captures with check but
not that rook first Bishop captures on
e7 with check King captures and only now
Queen captures on c5 with check King
Teti 8 and here if you want to continue
the game you have to win back some
material Queen III check Knight to e7
and now Queen captures on f3 where you
could trade down into this end game
where you are 5 points to but black is
up a knight so your your 3 points for a
piece but black shouldn't have any
problems defending this as this now this
point is just too far advanced and your
rook and Knight will be able to pick it
up
so Knight chapters on e7 interesting but
doesn't work so nice the c7 instead now
with ideas of Knights the e6 check but
it also hangs the rook on f3 so it's the
only move the only good move for alpha
black offa black captures that we have
Queen captures on f3 and now Knight the
e6 width check King t8 and now Knight
the c7 with check King back to a faith
Knight back to e6 with check King to e8
and it was in this position that alpha
white and alpha black agreed to a draw
unmoved 33 so 33 move game but probably
the well one of the most complicated
games ever played and it could have gone
either way like if you if you give any
of the positions like maybe let's start
from move 22 let's put two grandmasters
to play that position it will end up you
know maybe this one wins maybe this one
wins then you take two other
grandmasters and then you give them to
play position for a move 24 again we
would have fireworks on the board but
here both alphas of course they are you
know the the supreme chess entity played
it to perfection and Indian we had this
draw here it's a draw because white
can't push for advantage and black
cannot wiggle out of checks for example
it's 97 check if you try too high you
know run away with the King Queen to e6
is just me so black is definitely not
the one who can look for advantage and
if white tries something other than
Knight to c7 check let's the Queen to a4
check it's interesting but after rook d7
Knight c7 check King to d8 Knight back
the e6 check and now if black is
interested in continuing the game King
to c8 b7 check now you're hoping for
King captures and Queen captures rook
but black can capture with the Queen and
now the attack is just over you're down
too much material and of course the
black would win this so after King e8
our remarkable draw the probably the
greatest fighting draw that that ever
happened but it's remember this is not
real chess it's the chess variant where
castling is not allowed so here a
kramnik says that if this variant of
chess which is more well I don't know
more interesting to people then maybe
chess960 since it's basically the it's
not the same opening theory the opening
theory would vary drastically but still
it's at least something you have common
with with normal chess that may be the
you know the crowd would be more
interested in the games that there would
be a more decisive game see he suggests
that the number of the sizing decisive
games would be more than 50% and it it
would definitely be interesting and it
definitely might be the way to go to
make chess you know you know you know I
don't know if just were to maybe
experience another another Renaissance
or something like that but or maybe
maybe we'll just have everyone will have
alpha zero at home that can train you
and then you know people will start
playing very interesting just as well
but it's very unlikely that it will
happen under on the absolute highest
level where you know a cousin and and
well all the others are but yeah that's
the game alpha zero versus alpha zero
probably the perfect game I don't know
what are your comments on it and did you
enjoy it or maybe it was too complicated
there were so many lines and every move
could have had a separate video made for
it but I thought it would be I try to do
it in the most in a compact way that I
saw fit yeah basically that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Patrick Patrick Steinhauser
Michael Castagna and Richard Aukerman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and very
quickly we are starting our next big
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and do check out the original
article in the description below see you
soon